[Music]
foreign
did you know that Godzilla the king of
the monsters doesn't have an unbroken
winning streak he has lost his fair
share of battles and here are the six
monsters that have beaten him in a fair
fight the first one Mecca Godzilla the
robotic clone of Godzilla is indeed one
of his arch Rivals and one that is
actually a creation of humanity well
most of the time there have been three
different times that the mecca had
bested the G-Man in battle twice without
any aid from other kaijus or Monsters
the first was in Godzilla against
Mechagodzilla and it was a pretty even
fight through and through but in the end
Godzilla had to retreat back to the
ocean while a battered kill you
Mechagodzilla stood triumphant In The
City the second clean win was in
Godzilla vs Kong as we can clearly see
Mechagodzilla having the upper hand and
nearly killing the Big G if it wasn't
for cop intervening before he could
deliver the kiss of death yes
Mechagodzilla was killed by the team
effort of gong and Godzilla but in a
one-on-one fight the mecca clearly had
the advantage throughout the fight
number 2 King Kong the giant ape has
faced up against Godzilla twice in his
many decades of existence in the big
screen in Godzilla vs skull the Big G
was seen to be leaks ahead in power and
go had to resort to hit and run tactics
in order to actually temporarily win
around something that wasn't actually a
win but a temporary Lull in the fight
this isn't counted the Win For The Big
Ape was really in the 1960s movie called
King Kong vs Godzilla in this movie
Godzilla was the bad guy destroying and
rampaging his life away in Japan King
Kong had to be dropped and transported
to the fight and although Kong Lost the
first encounter and then was temporarily
knocked out in the Second Battle he did
manage to secure win by fighting the
king of the monsters in the end by
driving him off a cliff into the ocean
and when they both fell into the water
Kong was the only one that came out to
shore therefore securing a win
number three Master zero also known as
Ghidorah the three-headed dragon Master
Zero from the master verse was a Titan
that came from the stars and was a rival
apex predator to titanus Gojira most
zero secured a minor win in the first
encounter in Antarctica but this isn't
counted as Godzilla came back from the
hole in the eyes and gidarov led the
scene right after he was also nearly
killed by Godzilla in the ocean until an
oxygen destroyed weapon was fired at
both of them nearly killing Godzilla but
not affecting Master zero at all because
he had an extraterrestrial biology no
the win for Ghidorah was in Boston when
he carried off Godzilla into the sky and
dropped him off like a mic after a rap
battle gosler was clearly nearly dead
and would have been so dry of its
radioactivity if it weren't for the
intervention of Mothra and later by the
Russell family
number four guys a Ghidorah
maybe Godzilla final Wars the G-Man went
on a killing and winning spree all over
the world he beat Anguirus Rodan and
King Caesar all at once he even killed
azilla that was spawned by the zillion
aliens he also subdued kumanga Kamakura
hidorah and ever his final confrontation
was against Monster X a vaguely humanoid
Master that's like Ghidorah in a way
kind of like a pre-transforming type
while Monsta X and Godzilla were
essentially equals in battle Brazilian
Commander called X transferred his
energy to Monster X in order to
transform him into Kaiser Ghidorah this
four-legged ghidoro then gave Godzilla a
massive thrashing up to a point where he
was sucking and draining Godzilla of his
powers this would have been a clear win
if it wasn't for Ozaki transferring
Kaiser energy to Godzilla thereby giving
the Big G a massive power up and turning
the tables
the fifth monster Mothra the queen of
the Masters has had her share fear of
fighting both on the side of the king
against other monsters like Ghidorah and
Gigan as well as fending off Godzilla in
a couple of Encounters in the movie
Godzilla vs Mothra The Moth God teamed
up with another flying Kaiju called
batra in order to stop the G-Man from
destroying civilization this is
encountered as a win cause it was a
two-on-one fight and batra was killed in
the end no the fight that Godzilla lost
was in the old 1960s movie called Mothra
Vs Godzilla a name that's just the other
way around in there the aging and old
Mothra was killed by an atomic breath
fired by Godzilla in a fight but later
on Godzilla himself was incapacitated by
two Mothra larvae firing their silk on
him trapping him in a cocoon and sending
the king of the Masters to the Sea
and lastly Jet Jaguar yes the final
monster that defeated Godzilla was
another Mecca and this one is called Jet
Jaguar although in another time these
two teamed up to fight megalon and Gigan
and managed to scare a win in the anime
series however single a point it was jet
Jagger who was created by humans and had
to put a stop to the world ending
Godzilla Ultima Godzilla in this
timeline is a Kaiju made from a
trans-dimensional element called the
archetype jajwa however was the antidote
he was the orthogonal diagonalizer and
when this was triggered the archetypal
red dos element was dissipated and
Godzilla who was made out of this was
erased from existence but this isn't a
clean win as both the Mecca and Godzilla
were destroyed in the fight but still it
managed to achieve the objective
so I hope you're shocked by this list
and that you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam